c'est jour de finale à l'extérieur du
zénith le public se presse 5000
spectateurs survoltés sont venus
supporter les groupes de hip hop
une fois à l'intérieur l'ambiance
explosent pendant que des équipes
finalistes se prépare en backstage pour
elle l'enjeu est importante
gagner ici représente le rêve ultime les
championnats du monde à phoenix aux
etats unis cet été les premiers de
chaque catégorie verront leur billet
d'avion offert les deux autres seront
qualifiés mais devrait y aller par leurs
propres moyens
c'est avant tout bien sûr une
compétition il ya un enjeu derrière les
podiums pour représenter la france aux
états unis cet été
bien sûr ya cet enjeu on le ressent sur
scène mais ça reste avant tout un rendez
vous des passionnés
l'objectif c'est un monde mac les
danseurs dans le respect la compétition
américaine ont fait passer les coûts
dans le sens des croissants de sorte à
ce qu'ils aient impressions et donnent
le meilleur d'eux pourrait être regardé
dans quatre ans après la présentation
des crew le chou peut enfin commencer
en coulisses chacun sa façon de se
concentrer et de rester connectés bien
le tour des méga crew les danseurs dopé
crous et chauffe comme des athlètes
la pression monte ils sont les seuls à
représenter orléans en finale et il faut
coûte que coûte
allez à phoenix
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
terminera deuxième derrière les
bordelais de mega unity hills où quand
même qualifiés mais devront trouver le
financement pour jay city le chorégraphe
impossible de passer encore une fois à
côté de l'expérience des championnats du
monde
il faut qu'on y aille pas pouvoir dalloz
us liga c'est important de après une
validation de la danse quoi les jurys
nous ont dit vous êtes bon on voit même
c'est pas une première place une
deuxième place encore une fois quoi
voilà ce qu'on l'a fait depuis qu'on
fait les méga coup on n'a pas lâché le
podium donc on mérite notre place dans
en france dans la danse maintenant c'est
les us les usa rien à voir en termes de
niveau de danse et les championnats de
france de hip hop 2018 s'achève
certaines y auront à phoenix tandis que
d'autres repartiront la tête pleine de
souvenirs en nourrissant l'espoir de
revenir en août prochain
[Applaudissements]